>> Greg: LAST NIGHT A
LOW-LEVEL FORMER TRUMP AIDE WAS
ALL OVER THE NETWORKS.
ACTING ERRATIC, ANGRY, ARMED
WITH LITTLE REAL INFORMATION.
STILL, THE MEDIA ATE IT UP.
>> WHAT DO I HAVE TO SPEND 80
HOURS GOING OVER EMAILS?
IT WOULD BE FUNNY IF THEY
ARRESTED ME.
I THINK MY LAWYER IS GOING TO
DUMP ME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK MUELLER IS
GOING TO DO TO ME?
>> I AM NOT A LAWYER.
I I DON'T KNOW.
>> TRUMP MAY HAVE VERY WELL DONE
SOMETHING DURING THE ELECTION
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
IF HE DID THAT COME I DON'T
KNOW.
>> TALKING TO YOU, I HAVE
SMELLED ALCOHOL ON YOUR BREATH.
>> WELL, I HAVE NOT HAD A DRINK.
>> ANYTHING ELSE?
>> NO.
BESIDES MY MEDS,
ANTIDEPRESSANTS.
IS THAT OKAY?
>> NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: MSNBC CALLED IT
HISTORIC.
FOR EVERYONE ELSE IT FELT ODD.
REMINDS ME OF THE FOOTAGE OF
SOMEONE I AIRPLANE FLIGHT.
IT IS SO MUCH FUN TO WATCH.
OR WHEN SOMEONE LOSES HER TEMPER
AT THE STORE AND IS SHOWING A
CLERK.
WITH SO MUCH FUN TO WATCH.
JUST LIKE HIGH SCHOOL.
WHEN A FIGHT BREAKS OUT, WE
CROWN AROUND HER WATCH.
THANKS TO THE PLETHORA OF
CAMERAS, THE PERSON HAVING A
REALLY BAD DAY BECOMES A
DELIGHTFUL SEGMENT.
IT'S OBVIOUS HERE.
WHEN IT COMES TO NEWS, WE HAVE
LOST PERSPECTIVE.
IN OVERDRIVE TO FILL THE DAILY
RECOMMENDED ALLOWANCE OF
ANTI-TRUMP.
EVERYTHING BECOMES A BANNER
HEADLINE INCLUDING A POOR GUY
ACTING MANIC EITHER CAUSED BY
DRUGS, BOOZE, OR ROGER STONE.
HARD TO TELL THE ONE NEWSCASTER
ACCUSED NUNBERG OF DRINKING.
IF YOU SMELL THE BOOZE, WHY DID
YOU HAVE HIM ON?
WHERE THE OPTICS TO GOODRIDGE
YOU KNOW HE WAS GOING TO DUMP
ALL OVER TRUMP?
WE LOVE A GOOD MELTDOWN, REAL OR
CONTRIVED.
UNTIL IT'S US DOING THE MELTING.